[Musik]
schon oft haben wir auch visualpolitik
berichtet wie sich Russland militärisch
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine verrechnet
hat kurz vor und nach dem Beginn der
Invasion haben wir jedoch auch eine
Reihe von Videos über die ökonomische
Seite des Konflikts veröffentlicht denn
kein Krieg lässt sich ohne
wirtschaftliche Basis führen wir haben
euch darin putinsökonomische Strategie
Festung Russland vorgestellt mit der er
sein Land gegen die Sanktion des Westens
in Stellung gebracht hat seine
psychologischen Agenda mit der er die
Russen auf einen langen und
entbehrungsreichen Krieg vorbereitet hat
und natürlich die Maßnahmen der
Alliierten um seine Pläne zu
durchkreuzen auf den ersten Blick hat
sich die russische Wirtschaft seit dem
Ausbruch des Krieges als unerwartet
widerstandsfähig gegenüber den strengen
westlichen Sanktionen erwiesen doch die
Rückkehr zum Vorkriegsniveau könnte
extrem schwierig werden vor allem weil
immer mehr Spaß Ausgaben ist Militär
fließen müssen deswegen ist nun die Zeit
gekommen eine Zwischenbilanz zu ziehen
manche behaupten ja das potente
wirtschaftliche viel Kalkulation noch
viel krasser ausfällt als die
militärische andere sagen die Sanktion
gegen Russland seinen wirkungslos und
Russlands Wirtschaft so robust wie nie
zuvor sie würden dem besten mehr Schaden
als Russland also was ist dran an jeder
dieser Behauptungen wer hat Recht lasst
uns heute doch hierzu eine vollkommen
nüchterne Analyse durchführen
[Musik]
also wie ist die Ausgangslage nun die
Reaktion des Westens auf die russische
Invasion in der Ukraine war sehr
eindeutig einerseits er hätte letztes
Regierung tonnenweise Waffen und Geld
aus dem Westen andererseits wird
Russland bestraft mit einer Vielzahl von
wirtschaftsaktionen russische Schiffe
dürfen keine westlichen Häfen anlaufen
russische fliege nicht auf westlichen
Airports landen es gibt handelsverbote
für Waren aller Art wir sprechen hier
von einem der größten sanktionsprogramme
die durchgeführt wurden fakt ist die
Hilfe des bestens hat es den Ukrainern
ermöglicht den barbarischen Ansturm der
Russen zu widerstehen oft konnten die
Verteidiger den Spieß sogar umdrehen und
die Initiative ergreifen aber wie
erfolgreich sind die Sanktionen wirklich
haben sie die russische Wirtschaft
ausreichend oder waren sie eher ein
misserfolgung angesichts der Schärfe der
Sanktion entstand schnell die Erwartung
dass die russische Wirtschaft in Kürze
kollabieren würde sogar interne
Prognosen aus den Kräne sagten kurz nach
Kriegsausbruch voraus dass die
Wirtschaft im Jahr 2022 um mehr als 10%
schrumpfen würde diese Kanal hätte sogar
den Rückgang übertroffen der nach dem
Zusammenbruch des Sowjetunion während
der Finanzkrise 1998 bezeichnet wurde
tja Ende 2022 sah die Situation jedoch
ganz anders aus ja es stimmt dass das
Land in einer Rezession geraten ist aber
es hat zumindest offiziellen russischen
Angaben zufolge gerade mal 2,1% seiner
Wirtschaftskraft verloren und auch die
Staatseinnahmen haben nicht großartig
gelitten alles Sanktion zum Trotz
stiegen die Einnahme Russlands aus dem
Exporten von Öl und Gas im Jahr 2022
sogar noch an
russlandseinnahmen aus dem Öl und
Gasgeschäft in dem Laufe des Jahres
umfasst ein Drittel gestiegen die
Gasexporte gegen 2022 zwar mengenmäßig
zurück aber Russland exportierte mehr Öl
und mehr flüssig Erdgas als in den
Vorjahren und es verkaufte das alles zu
viel höheren Preisen darüber hinaus
führten Stein Kapitalkontrollen dazu
dass der Hobel auf ein siebenjahres hoch
steht auf den ersten Blick sieht also
alles danach aus als hätten die Sanktion
Russland überhaupt nicht geschafft im
Gegenteil es fließt immer noch
massenweise Geld aus den
Rohstoffexporten der Hobel rollt also
die Kosten des Krieges sind Peanuts
dagegen schaut euch mal dazu die
Zahlungsbilanz der russischen Wirtschaft
zum Ende des Jahres 2022 an
die Zahlungsbilanz ist quasi das
Ergebnis dessen was nach Handel und
Finanztransaktionen mit den Ausland
übrig bleibt wie ihr sehen könnt hat
Russland im Jahr 2022 eine Überschuss
von fast 250 Milliarden Dollar
erwirtschaftet viel mehr als im Jahr
zuvor es scheint also als würde es
Russland überhaupt nichts ausmachen dass
die Westmächte 300 Milliarden Dollar
Euro 2/3 der Währungsreserven des Landes
eingefroren haben denn das verlorene
Geld kam bitte die Jahresfrist quasi
durch die Hintertür wieder herein ich
meine ihr erinnert euch sicher noch
daran 28 Februar 2022 die G7 Staaten
haben alle russischen Währungsreserven
in ihren Ländern eingefroren ja aber die
fetten Gewinner aus dem Rohstoffgeschäft
haben für den eben gezeigten über in der
Zahlungsbilanz gesorgt und es deutet
vieles darauf hin dass die Explosion der
Rohstoffpreise eine starke Rolle
gespielt hat in Putins Kalkül die
Ukraine anzugreifen warum nun aus Sicht
des gremmels konnte es sich Europa nicht
erlauben hart auf einen Angriff zu
reagieren weil es nicht zuvor von
Russlands Rohstoffen extrem abhängig
gemacht und auch versäumt hatte eine
Alternative Versorgungsinfrastruktur
aufzubauen als Russland 2014 die Krim
annektierte wurde dieses Kalkül noch
ganz klar bestätigt wieso sollte man
dieses perfide Spiel also nicht auf die
Spitze treiben
[Musik]
und wenn man noch bedenkt dass Kriege im
allgemeinen immer die Preise für Öl und
Gas in die Höhe treiben so Rechte der
Kreml offenbar mit einer eher positiven
Bilanz des Krieges und mit einem sehr
billigen Waffengang aber wie steht es
heute wirklich um die russische
Wirtschaft wird sie die ökonomischen
Lasten des Krieges Sternen können
welchen offiziellen Zahlen aus Moskau
kann man überhaupt trauen wie sind die
Zukunft Aussichten und ist Russland
wirklich immun gegen westliches
Sanktionen acht bevor ich es vergesse
dieses Video wurde maßgeblich von
Konflikt auf nations unterstützt einem
doch thematisch ziemlich passenden Sport
so meinte ich auch schließlich geht es
heute ja und das trickreiche und
mehrdeutige Taktieren der großen
Weltmächte einem Spiel mit dem Feuer um
nationale wie geostrategische Ziele zu
erreichen auch unter einem kaufname
hoher Risiken und wer dieses
geostrategische Pokerspiel in einem
Online PvP Game selbst ausprobieren
möchte natürlich ohne das Schicksal der
echten Welt auf Spiel zu setzen für den
ist Konflikt auf nations free genau das
richtige darin übernimmst du die kon nur
über die Streitkräfte einer der global
führenden Nationen die für ihre
militärische Expansion wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung technologische Forschung und
internationale Diplomatie verantwortlich
ist es handelt sich um ein recht
beliebtes langzeitstrategiespiel das
sowohl auf dem PC im Bett Browser als
auch auf dem Handy gespielt werden kann
und bei dem in einem Match bis zu 100
Spieler miteinander um die globale
Vorherrschaft kämpfen du baust nach und
nach deine Infrastruktur und
Streitkräfte auf und beginnst dann Dinge
zu bekämpfen und Territorium zu
beanspruchen mit den anderen
menschlichen Spielern gegen die du
online antrittst kannst du checken und
auf diese Art eine vielfältige
Diplomatie entfalten das Konzept der
Langzeitstrategie von Konflikt auf
nations erzeugt dabei eine Art
bestechenden Realismus für das
langfristige Ringen um die
Weltherrschaft das Spiel enthält zwar
ein paar Elemente ist ansonsten jedoch
free to play das heißt du kannst dir
über den Link in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video einen vollkommen
kostenlosen Account einrichten und es
dann sowohl auf deinem Rechner als auch
auf deinem Handy spielen so lange du
möchtest und das Beste wenn du auf den
Link in der Beschreibung klickst
erhältst du als Bonus 13000 Gold in dem
und einem ganzen Monat Premium-Abo
gratis dazu dieses Angebot gilt nur für
30 Tage also zögere nicht zu lange und
fang am besten noch heute damit an deine
Truppen zu mobilisieren deine Allianzen
zu schmieden und siegreiche Schlachten
zu planen wie gesagt euch kostet es gar
nichts und uns helft ihr damit weitere
Informationen Videos wie dieses zu
drehen und falls euch unsere Videos
gefallen könnt ihr uns auch direkt
helfen und durch eine kleine
Aufmerksamkeit über den Spenden Link der
sich ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter
dem Video befindet wir danken euch schon
im voraus so und nun lasst uns in die
Tiefen der russischen Daten eintauchen
um dort den ultimativen Reality-Check
durchzuführen
Granaten kann man nicht fressen
eines ist klar bei Zahlen aus russischen
Quellen ist immer Vorsicht geboten es
handelt sich schließlich nicht gerade um
ein extrem transparentes Land die
Regierung ist besser enttäuscht und
tarnen als im öffentlichen korrekter
Wirtschaftsdaten im Jahr 2022 führte der
Kreml die Statistik Zensur ein eine
große Anzahl von Daten wie
internationaler Reserven oder auch
Handels und Produktionskennzahlen sind
heute nicht mehr verfügbar auch
Finanzberichte einschließlich die von
Privatbanken wurden eingeschränkt okay
keine Regierung veröffentlicht gerne
Daten die nicht positiv erscheinen da
tun sich manchmal auch Demokratien
schweren aber eine autoritäre Regierung
wie die Putins vergessen hat genau null
Interesse daran schlechte Zahlen zu
melden alle offiziellen Statistiken sind
daher erstmal das zu sehen was sie eben
sind Propaganda Material
wie der Internationale Währungsfonds
Putins gefälschte Statistiken naiv
nachplappert und dadurch seine
Wirtschaftsprognose für Russland
vermurkste Putin weigert sich wichtige
Wirtschaftsindikatoren offenzulegen die
außenhandelsdaten monatliche Daten zu Öl
und Gasproduktion Kapital zu und
Abflüsse Jahresabschlüsse großer
Unternehmen Daten zur Geldbasis der
Zentralbank da hatten zu ausländischen
Direktinvestitionen zur inländischen
Wertschöpfung nach Branchen sowie Daten
zur Kreditvergabe und Kreditaufnahme
diese sind jedoch die wichtigsten
hochfrequenzten Statistiken die in die
Erstellung einer gesamtwirtschaftlichen
BIP Prognose für eine Nation Einfließen
von den USA bis China der IWF verfügt
also einfach nicht über die Daten die er
bräuchte um das russische BIP nach einer
anerkannten Methode unabhängig zu
berechnen er schätzt im Blindflug
anstatt öffentlich zuzugeben was sie
nicht wissen geben Sie die massive
Unsicherheit nur hinter vorgehaltener
Hand zu die EWF Ökonomen für Russland
Produkten bedingungslos die wenigen
Daten die Putin herausgibt
herausgepickte und gefälschte Daten die
von der zunehmend unzuverlässigen
camel-agentur Rost statt veröffentlicht
werden und Putins mehr vom
wirtschaftlichen triumphälschlicherweise
bestätigen wir haben sogar mal ein
ganzes Video darüber gedreht wie ein
anderes totalitäres Regime nämlich China
seine Wirtschaftsdaten über Jahrzehnte
gefilmt hat und das war in
Friedenszeiten ich werde euch das Video
natürlich verlinken außerdem gibt es da
die vorigen Jahr starke
Kapitalverkehrskontrollen in Russland
die haben dazu geführt dass der Rubel
nicht wirklich seinen Marktwert
widerspiegelt an den internationalen
Währungsmärkten ist er praktisch
überhaupt nicht behandelbar und wenn
dann nur gegen chinesische gehören so
dass ein Kurs gegenüber Dollar und Euro
extrem verzehrt ist
aber warum ist das überhaupt so wichtig
und man braucht diesen echten Marktwert
um die tatsächliche Lage der Wirtschaft
zu beurteilen nur so erhält man
einigermaßen korrekte Werte für BIP und
für die Kaufkraft der Währung
schließlich bringt einem auf dem Papier
starke Währung nicht viel wenn kaum
jemand einem was dafür verkauft
die russische Industrie als auch der
Konsum Laufen zu den noch immer auf den
Steroiden die im letzten Jahr aus dem
wohlstandsfonds als massives
Subventionsprogramm in sie hineingepumpt
wurden und diesen Fonds wird erstens
bald die Puste ausgehen und zweitens
wissen wir alle wozu derartige
subventionsorgien in der Regel führen
noch mehr viel Allokation messwirtschaft
und Korruption klingt nicht gerade wie
nachhaltiges Wachstum den künstlich
aufgeblasenen Muckis der russischen
Wirtschaft Tod also das Schicksal eines
dopingsüchtigen Bodybuilders und es gibt
noch einen weiteren kraftfahrernden
Effekt bei russischen Wirtschaftsdaten
denn auch die Produktion von
Militärtechnik und Ausrüstung und deren
verbraucht durch das eigene Militär
tragen positiv zum BIP der Russen bei
für die einfachen Menschen in Putins
Reich bringt die sie doch keinen echten
wirtschaftlichen Mehrwert oder salopp
formuliert Granaten kann man nicht essen
[Musik]
die Dinger werden einfach an der Front
verschossen und verschwinden dann aus
der realen Welt aber in der
bip-statistik tauchen sie trotzdem als
Wertschöpfung auf es handelt sich hier
also um eine rein virtuelle Steigerung
des Volksvermögens keine reale erst
recht wenn man dabei ist den dadurch
gefütterten Krieg zu verlieren natürlich
für diese Umstand in jedem anderen Land
genauso zu einer Verzerrung des BIP auch
in den westlichen Staaten aber eine
russland ist der Anteil von Rüstung an
BIP besonders hoch und er hat durch den
Krieg wie ihr euch denken könnt noch mal
immens zugenommen seit also auf der Haut
vor kreativ präsentierten russischen
Statistiken aber wisst ihr was selbst
wenn man die russischen zahlen als
gegeben ansieht läuft es für den Kreml
und seine Wirtschaft schlecht
[Musik]
klar russlandswirtschaft hat im
vergangenen Jahr alle überrascht aber um
ein wirklichen repräsentatives
Gesamtbild darüber zu erhalten welche
herben wirtschaftlichen Rückschlag
putinskrieg für die Russen darstellt
muss man die ökonomische Dynamik des
Landes mit Jena vergleichen die
eingetreten wäre wenn sich der vorherige
Trend also ohne Krieg fortgesetzt hätte
und da sieht es verdammt düster aus
frühestens 2025 wird die russische
Wirtschaft wieder von 2021 erreichen
können wenn überhaupt und das war
bereits ein durch die corona-krise
gezeichnetes Jahr die Chance dass
Russland in den nächsten 10 Jahren
wieder auf den BP Level kommt dass es
ohne Krieg erreicht hätte ist gleich
null das Problem dabei Russland befindet
sich sowieso schon seit Jahren im
Niedergang vor allem demografisch aber
auch wirtschaftlich wir sprechen über
das flächenmäßig größte Land der Welt
mit einem 133 Millionen Einwohner das
russische BIP entspricht jedoch etwa den
von Italien wohnen 69 Millionen Menschen
leben statistisch erwirtschaftet ein
Italiener also mehr als doppelt so viel
wie ein Russe der Italiener
erwirtschaftet im Vergleich zum großen
jedoch einen viel höheren Mehrwert aus
eigener Kraft denn er kann nicht einfach
nur Öl und Gas aus den Boden Pumpen
sondern muss wirklich etwas
konkurrenzfähiges erschaffen können die
Russen hingegen sind bei so gut wie
nichts wirklich konkurrenzfähig eine
Ausnahme ist vielleicht noch die nuklear
Technik über die wir bald ein eigenes
Video bringen werden trotzdem unterm
Strich entspricht der Wert der Exporte
des Riesenreiches in etwa denen des
kleinen Belgien und das trotz aller
Rohstoffe die Russland in der Welt
verkauft aber das ist noch nicht alles
demografisch gesehen steht Russland am
Abgrund es ist hoffnungslos überall dort
und die Bevölkerung schrumpft seit dem
Fall des Sowjetunion
Russland Bevölkerungs ein Traum wird
noch schlimmer werden in Russland waren
sich eine demokratische Tragödie an in
den letzten drei Jahren hat das Land
etwa 2 Millionen Menschen mehr verloren
als unter normalen Umständen die
Lebenserwartung russischer Männer ist
umfasst fünf Jahre gesunken und liegt
damit auf dem gleichen Niveau wie in
Haiti sie sterben heute sechs früher als
Männer in Bangladesch und 18 Jahre
früher als Männer in Japan die Zahl der
Geburten im April 2022 lag auf dem
Niveau der Besatzung durch Hitler und so
wie es aussieht belasten die
Kriegsverluste die schrumpfende und
kränkelnde Bevölkerung noch mehr
Russland befindet sich wohl in einer
unaufhaltsamen Abwärtsspirale des
demografischen Niedergangs
1994 erreichte das Land mit 149
Millionen Menschen seinen
bevölkerungshöchststand in 50 Jahren
könnte laut unprognosen die
Gesamtbevölkerung bei 120 Millionen
liegen wenn die derzeitige Tendenz
anhält am stärksten war der Rückgang bei
den ethnischen Russen deren Zahl im
Zeitraum 2010 bis 21 um 5,4 Millionen
Sankt ihr Anteil an der Bevölkerung von
78 auf
72%. so viel zu Putins Prahlerei über
den Wachstum des Roski mir der
russischen Welt der demografische
Rückgang wird Russland insgesamt tief
greifen und zum Schlechten verändern
[Musik]
das Land steckt seit Jahren in der Krise
und sein Lebensstandard singt seit
langem lasst euch nicht täuschen von
Berichten über die reichen Russen von
Oligarchen das sind extreme Ausnahmen
nur mal ein kleines Beispiel das den
wahren Zustand des Landes verdeutlicht
Russland ist unter den entwickelten
Staaten China mit dem größten
Bevölkerungsanteil ohne Zugang zu einer
eigenen Toilette 45% der russischen
Haushalte sind nicht an eine
Kanalisation angeschlossen und 88 % der
Abwässer werden ungeklärt in die
russischen Flüsse und Seen gekippt und
eine für uns unvorstellbar große Zahl
von Russen muss ihren Notruf einfach in
einer verrichten und sie dann aus dem
Fenster kippen ja so mittelalterlich
sieht die Realität der normalen der
einfachen großen aus wenn Trumps Spruch
von shithol auf ein Land also
wortwörtlich zutrifft dann sicher auf
Russland aber fatalien sind nur eines
der vielen tiefen infrastrukturellen
Probleme des Landes die es oft auf einem
Level mit afrikanischen
Entwicklungsländern erscheinen lassen um
all diese Defizite anzugehen während
Investitionen in Billionen notwendig die
doch Putin und seine klettokratische
Blicke nie bewegen würden denn dann
würde ihm das Geld für ihren Luxus und
vor allem ihren Kraft fehlen
der Verfall der russischen Infrastruktur
und des Lebensstandards geht also runter
weiter und wenn die Sanktionen irgendwas
bewirkt haben dann dass sie diesen Trend
noch beschleunigt haben schaut euch zum
Beispiel diese Grafik an das sind die
Daten bzw Prognosen des IWF und der
Weltbank aus dem Jahr 2022 in nur zwei
Jahren nach dem Einmarsch in die Ukraine
könnte die russische Wirtschaft um 5 bis
8 % schrumpfen 2022 haben wir hinter uns
tatsächlich viel Putins Wirtschaft und
rund 3 % allerdings sollten aktuelle
Prognose des IWF Mitte Februar für eine
kleine Überraschung angeblich würde die
russische Wirtschaft 2023 sogar um 0,3%
wachsen darüber aber später mehr denn
abseits von zahlenspekulationen sind der
Lebensstandard der russischen
Bevölkerung rapide und das trotzdem im
letzten Jahrhundert Weltmarktpreise für
Rohstoffe und Energie diese sind
übrigens längst nicht mehr so gut wie
voriges Jahr aber auch dazu später mehr
kommen wir noch mal zum Thema Sanktionen
denn diese hatten drei Ziele erstens
Russlands wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit und
produktionsfähigkeit zu verringern
zweitens seine Rüstungsindustrie zu
schädigen um so russlandsfähigkeit zu
Kriegsführung zu schwächen und drittens
Russlands Energie und Finanzbeziehungen
zum Westen zu kappen und wisst ihr was
alle drei Ziele wurden weitgehend
erreicht wenn man die Sanktionen als
Wirtschaftskrieg sieht dann verliert
Russland diesen geradeaus hoch in einem
zukünftigen Video werden wir die
konkreten Folgen des Krieges unter
Sanktionen auf dem Handel die Industrie
und die Finanzen in Russland behandeln
hier geht es erst einmal um einen
Überblick zu den sanktions Folgen
die US-Regierung geht davon aus dass
Russland durch die Sanktionen bis 2030
etwa 20 Prozentpunkte seines BIP
einbüßen wird wir reden hier von einem
Betrag in der Größenordnung von etwa 300
Milliarden US-Dollar pro Jahr das sind
Verluste die dieses Land immer schneller
absteigen lassen die Kluft zwischen
Russland und den westlichen Ländern wird
immer größer so viel also zur Frage ob
die Sanktion den besten mehr Schaden als
Russland man sollte sich die Sanktionen
im Übrigen nicht vorstellen wie eine
Waffe quasi nach dem Motto Sanktion
verhängt die Wirtschaft crascht und
Russland ist nur noch ein Agrarstaat das
wäre ein vereinfachtes und übertriebenes
Bild das Medien und Politiker jedoch oft
zeichnen fakt ist das Land kann schon
noch selbst für sich sorgen und
industriegüte herstellen aber
entscheidend ist das alles wird durch
die Sanktionen verlangsamt es ist für
Russland viel umständlicher am
internationalen Handel teilzunehmen und
einen begehrte internationale Güter zu
kommen vor allem aus dem Westen
natürlich hat Russland einen
weitreichende System für grau Importe
über Drittländer eingerichtet und an die
Begehr südwestwaren heranzukommen aber
das alles fordert sein Zoll es kostet
viel Zeit und Energie und hält das
Wachstum und das macht die Kluft zum
Besten immer größer als bildlicher
Vergleich taugt bei den Sanktionen nicht
die Waffe sondern eher das schleichende
Gift das allmählich aber sicher lebt es
versteht sich davon selbst dass die
Sanktionen eher langfristige als
unmittelbare Auswirkungen haben ein Jahr
ist eine verdammt kurze Zeit damit die
Wirtschaft eines Landes komplett
zusammenbricht vor allem wenn es noch
über Reserven verfügt da jedoch
ausländisches und Teile fehlen wird zum
Beispiel die Fertigungsindustrie langsam
aber sicher den Bach runtergehen ich
muss immer weiter hinterherhinken und
kaum noch wettbewerbsfähig sein und
obwohl die Unternehmen vom Stadt
angewiesen wurden die Zahl der
Beschäftigten konstant zu halten und
dafür erhebliche Mittel aus dem
wohlstandsvor erhielten werden diese
Mittel langsam zu Ende gehen die
künstlich am Leben gehaltenen Firmen
werden langsam aber sicher Entlassungen
vornehmen weil ihnen der Cashflow
ausgeht und ihnen niemand mehr Geld
leihen will Jungs haben bereits drei
große Industrieunternehmen in Russland
umfangreiche Entlassungen angekündigt da
die auf aus dem Ausland schwinden wird
auch der elitäre IT-Sektor schrumpfen
die qualifiziertesten Arbeitskräfte
werden ins Ausland gehen wenn Sie dies
nicht schon getan haben kaputte Turbinen
Pumpen oder großen Motoren und andere
hochentwickelte Geräte oder ganze
Anlagen aus dem Ausland werden von
niemanden mehr repariert werden können
kurzum das erste Ziel des Sanktionen das
mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit erreicht
werden aber wie treffen die Sanktionen
nun die russische Rüstungsindustrie
konkret nun die Sanktionen wirken wie
ein Tiefschlag durch sie fehlen die
russischen Raketen Hightech Bauteile die
vorher aus dem Westen kamen modernes
Militärgerät kann kaum noch und vor
allem nicht in großen Stückzahlen
produziert werden vor allem nicht in
solchen Stückzahlen die die intensiven
Kampfhandlungen erfordern würden wir
haben Berichte von Ukraine das wenn sie
russische Militärausrüstung finden diese
volle Halbleiter ist die sie aus
Geschirrspülen und Kühlschränken
entnommen haben
potenzialindustrie verliert hierdurch
auch Aufträge aus der ganzen Welt und
das ist dann der Grund für Nachrichten
wie diese
Indonesien kauft US-amerikanische und
französische Kampfjets für 22 Mill
Millionen Dollar die russische su35 hat
das Spiel verloren Indonesien von einem
Deal mit Russland zum neuen
Kaufverträgen mit den USA und Frankreich
zeigt wie stark die US-Sanktionen wirken
das zweite Ziel der Sanktionen wurde
also auch erreicht und drittens ob wir
nun über Öl oder Gas sprechen Europa hat
es geschafft sich aus der Abhängigkeit
von russischen Energie zu befreien
Borell kündigt die Überwindung der
Energieabhängigkeit der EU von Russland
an diese Entwicklung haben wir übrigens
in einen früheren Video vorhergesagt ich
werde es euch der Vollständigkeit halber
mal lieber verlinken ihr seht also die
internationalen Sanktionen haben zwar
nicht den Krieg in der Ukraine beendet
und die russische Wirtschaft ist auch
nicht zusammengebrochen aber man sollte
nicht glauben dass die Sanktionen
nutzlos waren
[Applaus]
schaut euch mal diese Grafik an ihr seht
deutlich den Rückgang in allen Bereichen
des russischen Handels mit der EU der
einst wichtigste Handelspartner der
Russen fällt weg etwas womit Putin nicht
gerechnet hat hinzu kommt das
massenweise Unternehmen aus putinsreich
abwandern das Fachkräfte fliehen das
investorenreis Ausnehmen und das Land
international stark isoliert ist zu
behaupten dass die Dinge für Russland
irgendwie gut liefen wäre also ziemlich
grotesk und dann muss man doch bedenken
dass 2022 für den Kreml noch ein
karenzia war die hohen Energiepreise und
die in der Festung Russland gebildeten
dem Land eine schon frisst und diese
läuft in 2023 aus
6 März 2023 Russland Defizit springt auf
33 Milliarden Euro weil Putin kräftig
Geld ausgibt das russische
Haushaltsdefizit ist in den ersten
beiden Monaten des Jahres sprunghaft
angestiegen da blah die Map Putin
aufgrund der Sanktionen die durch seinen
Krieg in der Ukraine ausgelöst wurden
einen Einbruch der und gaseinnahmen
hinnehmen musste die russische
Wirtschaft hat sich im letzten Jahr
angesichts der westlichen Sanktionen als
unerwartet widerstandsfähig erwiesen
aber es sieht so aus als ob sie unter
Druck gerät da immer mehr Staatsausgaben
ins Militär fließen sie war gezwungen
internationaler Reserven zu verkaufen um
ein Defizit zu decken das durch die
Kosten des ukraine-konflikts entstanden
war das Schlimmste steht im aggressiven
Schurken Staat nämlich noch bevor schaut
euch mal diese Aussage genauer an bei
astronomischen Öl und gaseinnahmen
stiegen die Einnahmen im Staatshaushalt
insgesamt nur um 10%, die Ausgaben aber
um mehr als 20%. das deutet daraufhin
dass sich die Situation der öffentlichen
Finanzen verschlechtert und im Jahr 2023
kritisch werden könnte im Jahr 2022
erzielte der Chemnitz Ware kocht
Einnahmen aus dem Verkauf von
Kohlenwasserstoffen trotzdem sind die
öffentlichen Haushalte in die roten
Zahlen gerutscht und zwar so sehr dass
die russische Regierung empfindlich
sparen muss bei strategische wichtigen
Projekten im Jahr 2019 hatte sie zum
Beispiel prognostiziert das 2024 und 57
Milliarden Hobel in die Entwicklung
künstliche Intelligenz investiert werden
jetzt haben sich die Zahlen geändert es
werden nur knapp 25 Milliarden sein
unter der Zeitrahmen wurde bis 2030
gestreikt ein weiteres total
verbessertes vor dem griechisches Dorf
also die Preisfrage lautet jedoch was
passieren wird wenn die Einnahmen aus Öl
und gasexporten wirklich zusammenbrechen
nun passt gut auf denn genau das
passiert gerade
[Musik]
und ölpokalypse werden für Puten zum
Bumerang
die russische Regierung ist in hohem
Maße von Öl und gaseinnahmen abhängig
vor den Krieg erwirtschaftete dieser
Sektor fast 45% der gesamten
Staatseinnahmen dadurch kamen Devisen
ins Land um in Porto zu bezahlen und
ohne diese Importe hätte in Russland
noch größerer Mangel und stärkere
Rückständigkeit beherrscht als zu
verwehrzeiten aber wir waren die
Hauptkunden im Rohstoffgeschäft 0 Europa
war bei weitem ihr Hauptabnehmer und 60%
aller russischen Öl und Gasexporte
gingen dorthin aber auch die USA waren
ein wichtiger Kunde und beide Zeiten
sehr gut jetzt haben die Sanktion diesen
Markt auf dem Kopf gestellt
[Musik]
in den letzten Monaten haben die Länder
des Westens Öl- und Gasimporte aus
Russland verboten oder begonnen sie zu
beschränken aber die stärksten Maßnahme
kam im Dezember 2022 genauer gesagt am 5
dezember an diesem Tag trat die
Preisobergrenze für russisches Öl in
Kraft dieser Mechanismus trifft Russland
genau da wo es weh tut die
Preisobergrenze gilt für westliche
Unternehmen die Dienstleistungen im
Zusammenhang mit russischen Öl anbieten
z.B Versicherungen für Tanker sollte
Dienstleistungen dürfen jetzt nur noch
dann erfolgen wenn das russische Öl z.B
im versicherten Tanker zu maximal 60
US-Dollar pro Barrel verkauft wird und
es könnte durchaus sein das ist noch zu
einer weiteren Absenkung dieser Grenze
kommen wird außerdem gelten seit Anfang
Februar auch preisübergrenzen für
raffinierte Ölprodukte aus Russland also
Diesel und Benzin
das EU-Verbot und Ölpreis Obergrenze
sind endlich in Kraft getreten und die
Auswirkungen sind so erheblich wie
erwartet und dann und westliche Länder
kein Öl und Gas mehr aus langsam kaufen
sucht es natürlich nach alternativen
China und Indien boten sich dafür an
zufrieden sein können die Russen damit
allerdings nicht
denn im Vergleich mit Europa und USA ist
es längst nicht so lukrativ für Russland
diese Länder mit Öl und Gas zu beliefern
die Portemonnaies der chinesischen
indischen Käufer sitzen nicht so locker
wie die der Europäer sie nutzen die
Notlage der Russen bis zum Anschlag aus
und fordert enorme Rabatte das alles
lässt natürlich die Preise für
russisches Öl auf dem Weltmarkt
insgesamt Wurzeln in Kraft treten der
Ölpreis Obergrenze liegt der Preis für
oral bei rund 50 US-Dollar pro Barrel
das heißt der Markt hat die Grenze sogar
noch unterschritten die gewinnmarschen
der russischen Rohstoffkonzerne
schmelzen dahin
[Musik]
russisches Öl und Gasgeschäft gerät ins
Stocken nachdem die Sanktionen greifen
die russische Wirtschaft zeigt erste
Risse seit am 5 Februar dieses Jahres
strenge Beschränkungen für den Export
von Öl und Gas in Kraft getreten sind
bereits im Januar waren Russlands Öl und
gaseinnahmen im Vergleich zum Vorjahr um
46% gesunken da sich die westlichen
Länder von russischen Lieferungen
abgewandt haben dieser Rückgang wird
sich mit den Sanktionen vom Februar
voraussichtlich noch verstärken und als
ob das noch nicht genug wäre gleich in
die Exporte nach Asien den Verlust des
europäischen Marktes nicht einmal
annähernd ausschließlich gibt es nicht
annähernd so viele Pipelines nach China
oder Indien um so viel Öl oder Gas in
diese Länder zu punkten wie das im
Handel mit Europa der Fall war Russland
viele Jahre und enorme Investitionen
brauchen um hier eine tragfähige
Infrastruktur aufzubauen Investitionen
für die Folgen und hinten die Mittel
fehlen werden vor allem wenn der Krieg
viel Geld verschlingt und selbst wenn
die Infrastruktur nach Asien mal fertig
gebaut sein sollte man im Fall von
nordstring gesehen wie schnell die
jahrelange Aufbauarbeit wieder zu nichte
gemacht werden kann
die Verlagerung von Export nach Asien
wird nur eine begrenzte Wirkung haben um
den Verlust westlicher Märkte abzufedern
aber das ist noch nicht alles nach
Berechnung der finnischen Denkfabrik
Center for research und energy in clean
air könnte Russland im Jahr 2023 durch
die niedrigen sogar bis zu 200 Millionen
Dollar pro Tag verlieren das ganze ist
bereits jetzt ein riesiges
Verlustgeschäft weil der niedrige Preis
die Kosten nicht mehr deckt schon heute
verliert Russland dadurch
schätzungsweise jeden Tag 172 Millionen
Dollar und die jährlichen Verluste für
Russland könnten sich in Zukunft auf
etwa 100 Milliarden Dollar belaufen
in dieser Tabelle des russischen
Finanzministeriums könnt ihr sehen wie
sich die Staatseinnahmen bei
verschiedenen
produktions-szenarien in Ölsektor
ungefähr entwickelt
denn allein laut der offiziellen
russischen Daten sind 50 Dollar pro
Barrel die magische Grenze darunter
lohnt sich das ganze Geschäft für die
Russen nicht mehr denn sie können nicht
so billig fördern wie zum Beispiel die
Sonys die hohen Margen der vergangenen
Jahre kann Putin also vergessen da
müsste sein Öl schon zu Preisen von etwa
70 $ und mehr gehandelt und in viel
höheren Mengen gefördert und
transportiert werden und ja es stimmt
das Öl in der Vergangenheit schon zum
Preisen von 50 oder sogar 40 oder pro
Barry gehandelt wurde und Russland hat
das auch überstanden aber zu heute gibt
es zwei große Unterschiede in der
Vergangenheit hat die Regierung bei
niedrigen Ölpreisen die Notbremse
gezogen die Staatsausgaben gekürzt und
den Russen einfach den Gürtel enger
geschneit aber dieses Mittel hat Putin
mit seinem Ukraine Abenteuer eben aus
der Hand gegeben jetzt tobt ein ultra
teurer Krieg der immer mehr Geld
arbeitsfähige Bevölkerung und
Wirtschaftskraft verschlingt und
Russland zu weiteren Erhöhungen seiner
Staatsausgaben zwingen Russland erhöht
seine Militärausgaben nun stetig und in
Ste Tempo was letztlich die Entwicklung
der zivilen wirtschaftsinfrastruktur
behindert und 2023 fing für Moskau schon
mal katastrophal an steigende Ausgaben
und sinkende Einnahmen führten so
bereits im Januar zu einem
Haushaltsdefizit von 25 Milliarden
Dollar während sich der
Leistungsbilanzüberschuss gegenüber dem
Vorjahr mehr als halbierte diese Trend
wird sich im Jahresverlauf mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit noch erheblich
verstecken denn es fehlt vor allem wie
gesagt die Einnahmen aus dem
internationalen Handel wegen genau wegen
der Sanktion
außerdem reden wir hier nicht nur über
Öl das gleiche gilt für Gas
wollt ihr offizielle Daten nun
mengenmäßig ist der internationale
gasabsatz von Gazprom bereits im Jahr
2022 um 46% gesunken das Unternehmen
versuchte diesen Rückgang jedoch mit
höheren Preisen auszugleichen und der
hohe Gaspreis im vorigen Jahr spielte
den in die Hände normalerweise würden
die hohen Energiepreise dazu beitragen
den nationalen wohlstandsvor Russlands
aufzufüllen da die Exporte nun aber
Embargos und Preisobergrenzen
unterliegen ist Russland sogar derzeit
gezwungen chinesische Yuan und Gold aus
diesem Fond zu verkaufen und das Defizit
zu decken denn der Gaspreis liegt heute
viel niedriger und ist unter das Niveau
vor Kriegsbeginn gerutscht Tendenz
fallend Gastraum kann sein Gas heute
nicht mehr so teuer verkaufen wie vorher
also sieht es auch hier für die Russen
zarten duster aus
3 März 2023 russlandseinnahmen aus Öl
und Gas haben sich im Februar fast
halbiert die Staatseinnahmen aus dem
Ölgeschäft sind im Vergleich zum vorher
um 48% gesunken die Einnahmen sanken um
42% aufgrund geringerer Exporte nach
Europa zusammengenommen sind die
Steuereinnahmen aus Öl und Gas im
Februar gegenüber dem Vorjahr um 46% auf
6,9 Milliarden US-Dollar gesunken
Russland ist immer noch eine Energie
macht aber seine Rolle hat sich
dramatisch verändert Russland wird bei
Öl und Gas einen kleineren Marktanteil
haben weniger Gewinn machen und hat auch
einen Teil seines geopolitischen
Einflusses verloren die Sanktionen haben
die russische Wirtschaft vielleicht
nicht sofort zum Einsatz gebracht aber
sie haben ein sehr wichtigen Zweck
erfüllt indem sie das Land um Jahre
zurückgeworfen haben die Zentralbank hat
davor gewarnt dass das wachsende
Haushaltsdefizite die Inflation anheizt
sie erklärte dass sie die Zinssätze in
diesem Jahr eher von den derzeitigen
siebeneinhalb Prozent anheben wird als
sie zu senken Russland ist nun
Lichtjahre davon entfernt die für dieses
Jahr angestritten Ziele für Öl und
gaseinnahmen zu erreichen dieser
einnahmeziele braucht es jedoch um seine
budgepläne zu erfüllen und die
Kriegskosten zu stellen
russland hat die Energiekarte gespielt
und nicht gewonnen fatibel Roll exekutiv
Direktor der Internationalen
Energieagentur IEA nun muss es 2023
dafür auf den Plan B ausweichen das
heißt die nationalen wohlstandsform
massiv ernsthaften und die Wirtschaft
mit noch mehr billigen geldfluten
dadurch droht jedoch eine noch höhere
Inflation was die Zentralbank eben
zwingen wird die Zinsen und damit die
Kreditkosten zu erhöhen die Umsetzung
eines solchen Haushalts ist ein Weg zu
einer allmählichen Erosion der
Finanzstabilität und einem weiteren
Rückgang der real Löhne der Bevölkerung
das real verfügbare Einkommen in
Russland ist trotz Rohstoff Bums im
vergangenen Jahr bereits ein Prozent
gesunken was die Russen dazu veranlasst
hat mehr zu sparen und weniger
auszugeben der Einzelhandelsumsatz Sankt
dadurch um 6,7 %. die größere Spannung
daraus ist dabei ein eindeutiges Zeichen
für die wirtschaftliche Unsicherheit auf
die das Land zu steuert denn wie gesagt
dies alles geschah während die
energieeinnahmen noch punkten und der
Stadt dieses Geld in die Wirtschaft
Punkten wie wird es also erst aussehen
wenn 2023 die rohstoffeinnahmen
wegbrechen gut andererseits darf man die
russische Wirtschaften nicht als eine
schwarze weiß Bild betrachten die
Bevölkerung ist Entbehrung gewohnt und
die Führungseliten der russischen
Finanzinstitutionen wiederum sind daran
gewöhnt mit Krisen umzugehen es sind
immer noch dieselben Leute am Router
welche das Land durch die globale
Finanzkrise im Jahr 2008 und die sich
verschlechternen Beziehungen zum Besten
ab 2014 gesteuert haben
[Musik]
durchaus stolz auf sie sein denn sie
haben allen seinen extremen
wirtschaftspfeindlichen Aktion zum Trotz
die Strategie Festung Russland aufgebaut
ohne sie wäre das Land schon heute am
Boden diese Festung ist jedoch nicht nur
extrem trotzspielig ihre Belagerung wird
langfristig zu einem Verfalls Landes der
nur noch schwer wieder rückgängig zu
machen sein wird vor allem in einem
Umfeld mit niedrigen Rohstoffpreisen und
wenn sich die demografischen
Voraussetzungen ein paar Jahren noch
weiter verschlechtert haben und könnt
ihr euch noch an diese kuriose Meldung
erinnern über Autos ohne ABS die in
Russland beworben wurden oder über
Handys mit Tasten die wir sie aus den
aus einer 90er Jahren kennen nur das ist
nur ein kleiner Vorgeschmack denn das
ist es was gemeint Russland bleibt
sicher ein Industrieland nur aber eben
auf einem Niveau das weit unter dem
moderner westlicher Industrieländer
liegt die mittelalterlichen Zustände bei
der sanitätsinfrastruktur werden sich
auch auf die übrigen Lebensbereiche der
großen ausweiten es wird ein Gefälle
sein vergleichbar mit den Unterschieden
im Lebensstandard zwischen Ost und
Westdeutschland vor der
Wiedervereinigung nur noch viele krasse
und dieses Gefälle wird sich natürlich
auch auf die militärischen Fähigkeiten
des Landes auswirken jede Armee kann nur
so Leistungs- und konkurrenzfähig sein
wie die Wirtschaft auf der sie aufbaut
und wie die Gesellschaft aus der sie
entspringt dies gilt nicht nur in Bezug
auf Ausrüstung sondern vor allem auf
Bildung Vertrauen und soziale
Organisation komplexe Militäroperation
in moderner Auftragstaktik sind nicht
möglich mit einer ungebildeten Gruppe in
der eine dem anderen nicht vertraut und
nur darauf aus ist Waschmaschinen für
die Daheimgebliebenen zu klauen okay
jetzt argumentieren aber viele das China
Russland irgendwie helfen könnte in dem
es als Handelspartner einsprengt und
sich da eine Art Wirtschaftsblock als
Gegenmodell zum Westen entwickelt nun
wir haben dazu schon mal ein Video
gemacht dass ich euch verlinken werde
wir werden aber noch ein weiteres
Training an dieser Stelle nur so viel
China wird Russland nicht aus der Tasche
helfen können und wollen es wird eher
seine Schwäche gnadenlos ausnutzen Putin
hat also unfreiwillig vor allem ein Ziel
erreicht er wird als eine der russischen
Führer in die Geschichte eingehen der in
kürzester Zeit gewaltigen Wohlstand
vernichtet hat
wie sich die russische Wirtschaft im
Jahr seit Putins Einmarsch in die
Ukraine selbst verstümelt hat Putin ist
dabei Russland für die Weltwirtschaft
ihre relevant zu machen denn für die
Verbraucher ist es immer viel einfacher
und zuverlässige Rohstofflieferanten zu
ersetzen als für die Lieferanten neue
Märkte zu finden die Lieferketten passen
sich bereits an indem sie alternative
beschaffungsmöglichkeiten entwickeln die
nicht von Putins Launen abhängig sind
selbst Russlands verbleibende
Handelspartner ziehen offenbar
kurzfristige opportunistische Käufe
russischer Rohstoffe auf dem Spotmarkt
vor um von den niedrigen Preisen zu
profitieren anstatt in langfristige
Verträge und die Entwicklung neuer
russischer förder- und
Transportinfrastruktur zu investieren es
scheint das Russland auf dem besten Weg
ist seine schlimmsten Befürchtungen
Realität werden zu lassen zu einer
schwächenden Wirtschaftsnation zu werden
abhängig von China für das ist nur eine
Quelle für billige Rohstoffe darstellt
wird Russland erkennen dass es Putin
nicht braucht so wie die Welt bereits
erkannt hat dass sie Russland nicht
braucht nur dann haben die russische
Wirtschaft und die Menschen einen Chance
zum Wohlstand zurückzukehren
und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre
werden in Russland nun Stimmen laut die
eine Rückkehr zu zentraler Planung und
noch mehr staatlicher Kontrolle fordern
Planwirtschaft oder was nun wir werden
euch natürlich berichten ob solche
Experimente diesmal vielleicht gelingen
werden denn das wäre wirklich
revolutionär und eines ist auch sicher
in Washington reiben sich die
Geostrategen die Hände und können nur
staunen wieder autokratische möchte
gerne Rivale auf der Weltbühne seinen
eigenen Laden an die Wand fährt Russland
verliert in allen strategisch wichtigen
Bereichen beim Militär bei der Energie
und vor allem bei der Wirtschaft aber
jetzt interessiert uns was ihr denkt
glaubt ihr das Russland in der Lage sein
wird den neuen Sanktionen zu widerstehen
was denkt ihr was der kleine tun wird um
den Sturm zu trotzen können nicht
Sanktion den Krieg beenden oder
wenigstens verkürzen wie immer sind auch
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja geht uns mit deinen Leid halt
mit euren Freunden und vergesst nicht
das aber mit glücklich noch keins
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
vergesst bitte auch nicht das spannende
Online-Spiel unseres Sponsors Konflikt
offen nations kostenlos auszuprobieren
wenn du dich liest und zufühlen und über
militärische Strategien spekulieren
willst solltest du es unbedingt über den
Link in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video anspielen
[Musik]
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit unserer
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]